hey everyone welcome to biology
professor today is kind of a departure
from my normal style you know I'm
usually up in front of a whiteboard with
a prepared lesson but today I thought I
would just check in with you guys and
what you think about the corona virus
outbreak that has been getting so much
attention around the world the past
couple of months I've been talking about
corona virus a lot at the beginning of
each of my infectious disease classes
this semester and have found watching
this outbreak kind of unfold to be very
interesting from a scientific point of
view I thought that I would get here on
YouTube and just check in with you guys
mention a few things and then I want to
know how you've been affected by this
outbreak if at all right now I'm looking
at an article on the BBC News so it's
BBC com it's called coronavirus a visual
guide to the outbreak I'll put a link to
it here in the notes under the video
this article has been really cool
because they've been updating it pretty
much daily and so as of today February
21st I can see that there have been
thousands of cases most of them in China
more than 70,000 cases in China 75,000
now the death rate is still hovering a
little bit below 3% we do see that there
has been a drop in cases lately so
that's good also the daily death toll
has leveled out it'd be much better to
see that going down but at least it's
not increasing anymore
one thing I have found really really
interesting has been the comparison
between this corona virus called kovat
19 and two other corona viruses you
might have heard of so there was the
SARS outbreak a few years ago
Sahra stands for severe acute
respiratory center syndrome and then of
course MERS the which is the Middle
Eastern respiratory syndrome that's the
one that humans can contract from camels
and at least the
you know this coronavirus has been much
more widespread for only about two
months into this outbreak and there's
already you know almost 77,000 cases
around the world but luckily the death
toll is hovering like I said a little
bit below 3% whereas for SARS there was
only 8,000 cases total over about an
eight month period of time I believe
that outbreak was but the death toll for
that one was almost 10% and then MERS
there's only been about 2,500 cases ever
but almost 900 of those ended in death
so that's about a third of people dying
from MERS so luckily this coronavirus
the Cova 19 virus even though it has
infected many many more people much much
more quickly at least the death rate on
it is is much lower so that's something
that I'm grateful for of course I hope
to see no one else having to die
so hopefully the treatment programs can
be improved as we go forward cases of
corona virus outside of China there are
at this point as of today again it's
February 21st it's been recorded in 29
other countries two other countries have
entered triple digits Japan and South
Korea of course most of Japan's cases
are on board a cruise ship that is
docked off the off coast in Japan 15
cases in the United States
I'm grateful as a u.s. to this end that
that number has not gotten too much
bigger you know the symptoms are
respiratory there are things that we can
do to reduce our risk if we are in an
area where there is more corona virus
transmission things like cleaning our
hands covering the nose it's in mouth
avoid people with flu or cold like
symptoms things like that
and I guess that's sort of it for today
I just think that this has been
interesting watching this unfold I'd
like to know if it's affected you at all
other than being able to talk about this
with my infectious disease class I can't
say that it's really affected me
personally although I do know another
teacher who was trying to buy some face
masks for a class project and they were
they they couldn't find any all the
stores were out of face masks because
face masks are being used in China right
now China is where a lot of face masks
are made so less are being exported and
then of course China has asked other
countries to help it meet its demand for
face masks and so that means that there
might not be as many face masks in your
own local store as my fellow teacher
figured out recently so I guess that's
it for today leave me a comment if you
have any questions or any just anything
to say about this is outbreak and I look
forward to reading about it so thanks
for watching today bye